have utilized Twitter yes okay and is
your account at Marcus
a970-50645 that is absolutely not my
account okay that's not your account
well on December 5th 2022 an account
under the name Marcus Allen retweeted a
tweet that said that is not my account
ma'am I you haven't let me finish the
question sir the football player you
haven't let me finish the question on
this end the time is mine on December
5th 2022 an account under the name of
Marcus Allen retweeted a tweet that said
quote Nancy Pelosi staged January 6th
retweet if you agree and quote do you
agree with that statement yes or no
that that is I don't no ma'am that's not
my account at all I have I'm asking
whether you agree with that statement
yes or no can you please rephrase do you
think I'm the general lady has expired
staged January 6th I just want him to
answer no answer no answer yeah he'll
answer I'm just telling your time's up
do you believe that Nancy do you agree
with the statement that this person
tweeted that Nancy Pelosi staged January
6th yes or no no thank you
it's not his account anyway joining us
Now to respond the attorney representing
both Marcus Allen and the IRS
whistleblower in the hunter Biden case
Tristan Levitt is with us Tristan thank
you welcome aboard
thank you pleasure to be here uh why do
you think that there is a dual justice
system because I don't have any doubt in
my mind that we have that
well that's a complicated question but
clearly one of the factors has been that
those that are in the ruling part of the
FBI and in in other places have a one
party mind one ideology and one way
looking at things and those that
question and challenge that they're very
willing to to attack
all right so you how hard is it for a
decorated combat Marine like Marcus
Allen to have the FBI questioning his
allegiance to his own country a man that
put his life on the line for all of us
in Iraq how does that feel for him
it's very disconcerting for him he's
simply all throughout been trying to do
what he believes is right he is a person
of Faith he's someone that is Guided by
his conscience and he's just been
playing trying to play this straight and
so for the FBI to treat him the way that
it did to begin with and then for him to
have this kind of treatment subsequently
you see you saw that that exchange there
with him Sanchez and that kind of
treatment is precisely why he opted to
not be interviewed by the Democrats
initially this is how they treated Steve
friend and George Hill in earlier
interviews and he saw that they released
a report explicitly going after them
smearing these individuals so you know
when when they act that way it it tells
you exactly what it is that they're
after but so for him this has been very
disconcerting all right so your client
now has been suspended do you believe
this is retaliatory and what recourse
what remedy might he have
yeah so we we actually Empower oversight
which I'm the president of actually
represents both Marcus Allen and Steve
friend but so Mr Allen uh has has had
his clearance suspended he we have filed
a complaint with the Department of
Justice office of Inspector General and
so they have the jurisdiction it's a
very weak process for investigating
retaliation through the means of
suspension of security clearance so it
requires that they wait a year after
that happens but he's reached the year
mark he's I think is 16 months without a
paycheck since his clearance was
suspended and uh so we're we're very
happy that the doj inspector General is
looking at that he'll be interviewed by
them tomorrow and we're confident that
they will help uh you know help to write
things there because his is a very
straightforward case of whistleblower
retaliation do you believe that the FBI
at the top leadership is now trying to
stop whistleblowers like your client
from coming forward to silence them and
are they intimidating them and are they
harassing them and are they violating
what whistleblower protection laws
yes to the first three the the fourth
one's a little bit tricky so they're
using security clearances because that's
a method they have available to them
other agencies I've seen do that before
in my career working on Capitol Hill as
an investigator but the FBI right now is
particularly aggressively using the
suspension of clearances as a way to go
after whistleblowers part of the reason
that they are able to do this is because
the FBI does not have strong
whistleblower protections when the
modern system of Whistler protections
was passed in 1978 the FBI was given a
special exception it's not that long
after J Edgar Hoover and uh and they
they have had a lot of cloud although
obviously their friends and allies have
been diminishing as their their recent
Stripes have come to light but that's
allowed them to be able to get away with
quite a bit that other agencies wouldn't
absolutely chilling we wish your clients
the best thank You Tristan we appreciate
it